all right everybody 2021 Honda Civic
we're going to be trying out the X tool
on this one uh we got to program two
keys to the vehicle there is one key
that's already programmed but this does
not go to this
[Music]
vehicle mistaking and these ones do
so uh we'll go Auto search
[Music]
now Smart Key System button to start
okay we are not please turn on the
ignition switch
yes uh we're going to add smart
Keys
whoa all right sorry about that so all
smart keys are out of the car except for
one
okay turn ignition on with a switch yes
we're going to add a smart
key vehicle is recognizing the key I'm
just going to put the key the key cannot
be recognized please make sure the key
is
programmed okay so that's a little bit
weird all right let's try this
again with the KE does
work but now I got the key that actually
works in the car
[Music]
oh yeah that's
weird
[Music]
no okay just turn on the
ignition yeah
yes take the smart key out of the car
and put a new smart key into the car
perfect let's try
this
[Music]
okay if it's going to turn the ignition
Wich off within 15
seconds
okay ignition switch turned on turn the
ignition switch
off
perfect the ignition switch
on whether security indicator light is
off and they are off from what I can
tell perfect
see if it starts the car oh he has the
brakes so I won't be able to do that
right now uh yes switch off the
[Music]
ignition program success all right so
now we're going to add another key to
the car
again uh we're going to read the number
of
[Music]
keys keys number is two so now we're
going to add one
more okay we're going to add a smart key
please turn the ignition on yes I
can vehicle is recognizing the
key take the smart key of the car and
put a new smart key into the
car smart keys are out of the car new
smart Keys is into the car
okay we're
communicating I just like to hold the
back of the key up to the button that's
my preference
doesn't have to be switch it
off
okay switch it
on perfect switch off the
ignition switch on the
[Music]
ignition and the lights are
off Keys work
switch off the ignition switch on the
ignition and program success so that's
it on programming 2021 Honda smart keys
on to uh a Honda Civic using the X da8
Bluetooth uh hope you guys enjoyed it
and I'll see you guys next time
[Music]